(Tate)
Ah, the old submopod.
You know, your mother and I
conceived you
in a vessel like this.
Dad, that--
that's inappropriate.
No, no, no, no,
it's fascinating.
How did you find the space?
Well, she kinda shimmied up
the side.
Can I--Can I--
Can I show you?
Sure.
Am I you or your wife?
- Ugh.
- No, I'm me.
And then if you just scoot up
and spread eagle.
- Ugh.
- Like this?
Not quite.
She had her leg
up on that panel.
- And she--
- No, don't.
Let me just
adjust your hips.
Stop it!
Not now, Chrysalis.
Daddy's busy.
FYI, I'm very comfortable
with my body.
So just really invade
my personal space.
[hoarse murmur]
Dad, stop!
[rattle, all screaming]
Oh, my God!
[overlapping yelling]
Agh!
Look, Dazzle.
It's Splasha, your girlfriend.
Thank God.
Splasha, I've missed you
so much.
I know!
Every second we're apart
is like a million eternities.
No, you try and keep up.
[laughs]
[upbeat music]
♪ ♪
♪ I see your fin
begging my to play ♪
♪ As silver angels
chart the course ♪
♪ With their echolocation ♪
♪ I wipe a tear
as the blow holes spray ♪
♪ Wise old Mr. Octopus ♪
♪ Applauds in celebration ♪
♪ Never thought that
I would know my destiny ♪
♪ Till the day I saw
a thousand eels ♪
♪ And called it harmony ♪
♪ I kissed a reef
in Aquatica ♪
♪ Never going back to all
those stupid dicks on land ♪
♪ Oh yeah ♪
♪ ♪
♪ I kissed a reef
in Aquatica ♪
♪ The kissed a reef ♪
♪ I touched a cod ♪
♪ In Aquatica ♪
♪ I met a squid
in Aquatica ♪